tu as peur de repartir en prison
bonsoir José Beauvais
bienvenue parmi nous sur le plateau tout
le monde en parle mais vous n'êtes pas
en train de courir après le plutonium
non
j'ai appelé les gens à le faire j'ai
appelé les gens à le faire toute la
semaine pour moi c'est important c'est
indispensable ce qui se passe là est
complètement aberrant on fait traverser
du plutonium à travers les océans
ensuite on le met sur des camions on le
fait traverser la France par la route
au moment où tout le monde nous parle de
sécurité on nous rabâche avec la
sécurité on est en train de faire de
transporter comme ça des bombes qui
pourraient être en fait
à raisonner par n'importe qui n'importe
qui pourrait avec un bazooka tiré sur
ses camions c'est quelque chose qui est
complètement aberrant oui c'est ça que
vous craignez en fait c'est l'attentat
parce que sinon à l'intérieur du camion
ça craint rien quand même non a priori à
l'intérieur du camion ça craint rien
mais effectivement il peut y avoir un
attentat on sait très bien ce qui s'est
passé dans l'ex-Union soviétique il y a
eu aussi des vols donc lui on fait
circuler ce genre de produit plus il y a
des risques qu'il en partent quelque
part dans la nature ça se vend très cher
ça se vent très cher il y a des gens qui
sont prêts en acheter beaucoup donc moi
je trouve ça absolument invraisemblème
surtout qu'il y avait d'autres
possibilités on pouvait le stocker le
vitrifier avec d'autres déchets et les
stocker là où ça a été produit donc là
c'est utilisé en fait c'est déchets
plutôt que les enfouir c'est là ce
qu'ils veulent en fait c'est utiliser la
technologie d'Areva donc le groupe
français faire du business avec ça pour
pouvoir ensuite leur envoyer aux
États-Unis et leur vendre la même
centrale pour refaire ce combustible là
on est dans un système cinglé on a vu
quand même quelques quelques écologistes
essayer de s'attaquer un bateau camion
etc enfin on peut pas dire quand même
que les Français soient couchés en
travers des autoroutes quand même c'est
pas c'est pas une mobilisation très
massive non je pense que les réseaux qui
avaient lancé ça voulait d'abord alerter
l'opinion publique ils sont dans une
phase d'alerte puisque après ce camion
là en fait ses premiers déchets il y en
aura d'autres a priori qui sont prévues
donc je pense que la mobilisation va
aller grandissante ils ont essayé et bon
là je voudrais notamment
parler de gènes régulières
qui est quelqu'un de formidable que je
connais bien et qui est un type extra et
qui a est tenté lui de rentrer dans le
port il s'est fait arraisonner son
bateau donc j'espère que que la marine
française va lui rendre son bateau voilà
et en plus ça coûte 75000 euros quand on
s'approche trop près des des bateaux
c'est ce qui a décidé le tribunal donc
c'est à dire que là le tribunal est aux
ordres d'Areva on leur a mis ici vous
approchez à moins de 100 mètres des
bateaux vous avez 75000 euros à moins de
100 mètres des camions 75000 euros et ça
s'arrêtera ou donc là c'est vrai que la
prochaine fois il faudrait qu'il y ait
des milliers de gens et vous y voyez une
militarisation de la société je pense
que le nucléaire amène automatiquement
immitalisation de la société parce que
ça fait partie de ces technologies qui
nécessitent une protection absolue
ensuite un état de plus en plus policier
parce qu'il va falloir le garder le
problème c'est qu'on sait pas pendant
combien de siècles donc dans 1000 ans
qu'est-ce qu'il en sera et ça ce sont
des cadeaux empoisonnés aux générations
futures parce qu'on ne sait pas quoi
faire des déchets qui vont rester
derrière que c'est une chance que vous
soyez avec nous ce soir José Bové
puisque le procès des 8 faucheurs d'OGM
dont vous et Noël mammaire qui devait
s'ouvrir le jeudi 16 septembre a été
repoussé au 8 novembre à Toulouse donc
ça vous ça vous permet
alors tout ça c'est pour avoir détruit
des champs de maïs transgénique à
Montville le 25 juillet alors les autres
faucheurs d'OGM risque 50 prisons et
encore une fois 75000 euros d'amende
c'est prisonnier etc je pense que
Sarkozy a besoin de faire entrer des
sous donc c'est 75000 chacun c'est 75000
c'est tarifs et alors vous c'est le
double parce qu'il y a récidive donc
vous c'est 10 ans de prison et 150000
euros d'amende j'ai commencé à faire
cher quand même là on arrive dans
l'absurde parce qu'on a chaque personne
qui était présente ce jour-là Mainville
à peu près un millier de personnes ont
arraché chacun un pied de maïs et donc
10 ans de prison pour un pied de maïs
c'est quand même pas mal puis bien sûr
bon alors c'est pas fini j'osais mauvais
puisque vous avez remis ça le 5
septembre dans le dans le Gers vous
dites c'est la première fois que je vois
des forces de l'ordre tirer sans
sommation sur les élus de la République
exactement c'est ce qui s'est passé le
25 septembre dans la Vienne
ce jour-là un défilé avancé et à 300
mètres avant de rentrer devant les
gendarmes qui s'étaient d'ailleurs
enfermés dans des barrières donc il m'a
aucun chance de pouvoir rentrer sans
sommation tir de Grenelle les crimogènes
sur les élus
grenade lacrymogène et ensuite grenade
offensive c'est-à-dire ce sont des
grenades assourdissantes en ferraille
donc c'est du fer blanc et quand ça
éclate et bien les gens prennent des
blessures on a eu trois il y a eu 20
blessés ce jour-là dont trois
journalistes un journaliste de Reuter un
photographe un caméraman de France 2 et
un cameramen de LCI qui ont été blessés
par les par les tirs vers les
journalistes ont été ciblés directement
ce qui a amené une protestation
notamment de reporters
alors le ministre de l'Agriculture Hervé
Gueymard a dit que c'était brutal vos
méthodes quand même oui c'est le cri du
pied de maïs qu'on arrache c'est quelque
chose d'insupportable en fait justement
je vous ai Beauvais sur le fond à Marsa
près de Clermont-Ferrand ont été
détruits des champs de maïs l'espèce en
question l'espèce étudiée résiste à la
sécheresse et demande moins d'engrais
chimiques que les autres espèces alors
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en train
finalement de faire une énorme connerie
99% des OGM sont faits pour résister à
un herbicide ou être insecticide parfois
ils essayent en plus de rajouter
d'autres effets mais la question de la
sécheresse il y a pas d'eau une plante
peut pas pousser donc en plus si c'est
ça on le fait pas à Marsa en plein
milieu de l'Auvergne qui est un endroit
où il pleut tout le temps alors on fait
ça dans le sel dans ces cas-là alors
comment vous expliquer que les
destructions que vous pratiquez avec vos
amis soit dénoncés par Pierre-Gilles de
Gennes quand même prix Nobel de physique
et 1500 scientifiques alors ce qui est
clair c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'Académie
des Sciences a très clairement
choisissons quand en disant qu'elle
était pour les OGM d'ailleurs souvent
sur des raisons économiques et sociales
qu'elle n'a jamais pu vérifier donc
c'est assez intéressant Pierre Gilles de
Gennes c'est pas un âne quand même si
dit ça c'est quand même prix Nobel ouais
mais le fait d'être pris une belle de
physique ne donne pas forcément
qualification pour parler de biologie
alors il y a un sondage quand même un
sondage CSA dans lequel on voit que 74%
des Français pratiquent l'appellation
trouve les faucheurs de GM alors c'est
curieux parce qu'il y en a eu un autre
qui est sorti dans qui a été fait par
l'Ifop pour Ouest-France qui dit qu'en
gros 50% des Français approuvent les
fauchage les autres les désapprouve ce
qui est évident c'est que c'est une
action qui était légale et c'est vrai
que souvent les gens sont pour le
respect de la légalité
je le comprends complètement et quand je
mène ces formes d'action je sais que je
fais quelque chose illégal mais j'assume
la responsabilité le faire donc si je
vais en prison pour ça je l'assumerai
oui évidemment pour votre défense on
peut dire que si les militants avaient
détruit les stocks de sang contaminés
par le virus du sida avant que le sang
soit donné aux hémophiles il y a 15 ans
il serait pas arrivé tout ça c'est vrai
exactement mais c'est un peu aussi comme
les militants anti IVG qui attaque les
cliniques où il y a des avortements vous
en pensez quoi de ça c'est le même
procédé finalement alors c'est pas le
même procédé parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que quand on mène ses
actions on le fait par rapport à un
débat on demande à ce qu'il y a un débat
public et on veut pas que nous impose à
l'ensemble de la société à
l'environnement des effets qui seront
irréversibles il faut un débat public il
faut qu'il y ait un référencement le
débat public il a eu lieu on a eu des
République loi qui a été votée donc
voilà
ce qui est insupportable avec des anti
IVG c'est qu'au nom de leur propre
religions ils veulent imposer à toute la
société une norme qui va que pour ceux
qui sont d'accord avec leur préceptes
alors on en arrive à la désobéissance
civique
c'est là-dessus que vous publiez un
livre avec Gilles Luneau qui s'appelle
pour la désobéissance civique alors
voilà si vous chez vous vous voulez
pratiquer la désobéissance civique d'un
certain immédiatement il y a un certain
nombre de conditions à remplir d'abord
faut être responsable cette fois assumer
les sanctions vous vous acceptez la
langue on va voir au moins 75000 euros
faut le dire effectivement il faut être
désintéressé ça peut pas être par profit
personnel sinon ça serait trop facile
non violent enfin en tous les cas sur
les personnes sur les personnes sur les
pieds de maïs sont les personnes
transparents ça doit se faire au grand
jour et
ultime il faut avoir essayé tout le
reste sur les OGM vous partez du
principe que tout a été essayé tout a
été utilisé et aujourd'hui vous pouvez
vous permettre de pratiquer la
désobéissance civique mais c'est parce
qu'il nous semble qu'aujourd'hui des
débat est complètement bouché qu'on
n'arrive pas à avancer on a plus de 2500
mères qui ont pris des arrêtés anti OGM
les tribunaux cassent ces arrêtés
systématiquement 16 régions déjà sur 22
en France ont décidé d'être hors OGM or
on leur dit cette illégal donc on est
dans un système complètement bloqué et
c'est par rapport à ça que les citoyens
ont dit mais s'il nous reste plus qu'une
chose c'est de désobéir nous allons
désobéir le premier exemple de
désobéissance civique ça a été la
Révolution française j'imagine
c'est-à-dire que les gens sont descendus
dans la rue un jour pour pour désobéir
et pour plus faire comme on leur disait
il y a eu aussi le droit de grève qui a
été obtenu comme ça le droit de vote des
femmes l'IVG l'objection de conscience
les ravioles
on s'aperçoit effectivement qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'avancées sociales le
tirage du Loto le mercredi il y avait un
tirage à l'époque grâce à une
mobilisation générale je crois qu'on est
arrivé à nos fins
là je crois que il y a il y a une
histoire qui me paraît quand même la
plus belle
c'est l'histoire des femmes d'Athènes
qui a été racontée par eristophane qui
était un écrivain
l'illistrattaque est une femme qui a
organisé les femmes d'Athènes parce
qu'elles en avaient marre de voir leurs
hommes se faire tuer à la guerre donc
elles ont décidé de faire la grève de
l'amour tant que continuerait de faire
la guerre contre
et les hommes ont craqué à la fin
première exemple de désobéissance
civiques effectivement alors c'était
inventé par rapport un écrivain
américain qui s'appelle Henri Toro qui a
été emprisonné en 1846 pour avoir refusé
de payer l'impôt dans un état le massage
sucette
dans ce fameux état donc il voulait pas
payer d'impôts parce que l'État ne
voulait pas abolir l'esclavage
comme Florent Pagny
c'était le pionnier de la région et
c'est le premier qui a dit la
désobéissance civile c'est la façon dont
les individus peuvent réagir dans un
état démocratique et de non violence
parce que Gandhi a bien repris aussi
derrière
dont on a très peu parlé mais bien connu
alors voilà donc en fait taureau
revendique le droit à transgresser une
loi injuste c'est-à-dire quand la loi
apparaît injuste on se donne le droit de
la transgresser sa responsabilité
puisque lui-même est allé en prison il a
été incarcéré pour avoir refusé de payer
cette impôts il a dit moi je n'accepte
pas comme mon argent servent à faire des
choses qui vont contre l'intérêt général
qui Bafou les droits de l'homme puisque
vol donc ça veut dire que les élections
servent à rien alors si vous développez
la désobéissance civique mais disons que
comme on l'a souvent dit et comment on
l'a écrit c'est que la désobéissance
civique peut-être une respiration de la
démocratie c'est-à-dire que on va plus
loin c'est à la démocratie c'est pas
simplement voter tous les 6 ans c'est
aussi s’engager dans sa vie quotidienne
et agir au quotidien pour que cette
démocratie soit vivante si on attend
simplement qu'on va élire des
représentants et qu'ensuite on reste
chez soi rien ne va avancer rien ne
bouge voilà donc José Bové Gilles Luneau
la désobéissance civique c'est publié
aux éditions de La Découverte José
est-ce que vous avez le temps de voir
vos enfants avec tout ça elles sont
grandes il y en a une cabane 9 ans et
l'autre 27 ans ouais donc je les ai plus
au téléphone que
devant moi oui alors comme vous les
voyez pas très souvent elles m'ont
chargée de vous poser quelques questions
interview expliquées à ma fille
[Musique]
dis papa
paysan ça gagne du blé
pas trop
pourquoi tu es toujours à la télé j'ai
mal à la ferme papa
comme ça au moins je peux vous voir
tu aimes bien faire la vedette papa non
c'est jamais été
pourquoi j'ai pas le droit d'aller au
McDo avec mes copains
parce qu'elles ont décidé elles-mêmes
que je trouvais pas ça bon parce que
papa la cervelle d'agneau tu crois que
c'est meilleur que le Big Mac
incontestablement
tu as peur de repartir en prison
c'est quelque chose dans lequel je pense
je suis prêt à l'assumer mais c'est
jamais avec plaisir qu'on va en prison
chaque personne qui est en prison tu
fais toujours un plan sur la comète pour
t'évader c'est tout ce que tu dis là bas
il paraît
et pourquoi moi je dois t'obéir papa si
toi tu obéis à personne ah j'ai jamais
demandé de me dire toujours et mes
filles m'ont souvent résisté et
heureusement quand il y a des caméras tu
es encore plus courageux ou non non ça
change rien
tu aimerais que je sois paysanne moi
c'est vraiment alors c'est leur choix
elles ont le temps de choisir elles
peuvent toujours le faire dans 100 ans
papa tu vois qu'il y aura encore des
paysans
j'espère parce que sinon ça va être
vraiment la fin de la planète pourquoi
tu voulais pas qu'il la ferme
parce que je pense que c'était vraiment
con ah non c'était bien on a regardé on
était à fond dans l'eau
je pense que c'était grotesque non ça
n'avait pas ça n'avait aucun sens à
limite que les gens fassent un show de
ce type là mais ce qui était pas sympa
pour les téléspectateurs c'est qu'il
voyait pas le derrière de la ferme on
n'a pas vu la belle piscine on n'a pas
vu tout ça donc c'est vrai que c'était
vraiment du cinéma quoi cet embêté qu'on
voit qu'on peut faire ton boulot avec
des Talents Hauts papa
c'est à dire que peut-être que pour
marcher dans le fumier c'est mieux parce
que au moins on s'accroche pas tu as
déjà pris de la drogue papa oui j'ai
fumé oui bien sûr
pourquoi tu cultiverais pas de la drogue
en disant que c'est la désobéissance
civile papa bah écoute chez moi ça
pousse pas très bien et elle le savent
il y a pas beaucoup d'eau donc je crois
pas qu'on aurait des très beaux pieds
c'est obligé la moustache et la pipe
quand on est paysan papa je crois pas
parce qu'il y en a pas mal d'un verre
aussi maman elle dit que tu adores les
pipes c'est vrai
j'adore ça et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu